california california california
the middle class famous tour is coming
to the left coast yeah guys april 3
we're going to be in san francisco april
4th we're going to be in los angeles
april 6 we're going to be in la jolla
get your tickets now it's a little bit
of stand up it's a little bit of ayg
it's a whole lot of fun do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians we
find out they're good to be glasses
uh-huh or if they're just a big old
piece of [ __ ] trash i'm your host nate's
foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at auntie's basement
she's back from spring break okay
abruptly oh
she had some trouble with the girls down
there
one of her implants blew up
ah we're having a good time my co-host
is coming at you from across the table
this is a family episode we're circling
the wagon
i knew you were gonna say that
he's the ceo of ru garbage and it's
coming around paycheck time so show them
a little respect you know put in a good
word for me leave a nice yelp review hey
the fat guy's great we love them trying
to keep me around here my fat waiter ate
my mozzarella sticks
i'm trying to unionize over here toby's
playing hardball real communist to that
kid give it up for kj
kevin james ryan hey pal hey gang thanks
i got the giggles today thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes those
review numbers those are almost true to
roof fantastic those are getting a
second second set of legs on them
obviously full video available on
youtube those numbers are true to roof
cooking don't got on youtubes then um
[ __ ] i don't know what patreon.combacks
i saw you garbage come on what are you
doing
patreon.com baby sign up get bonus
episodes of ayg episodes of hard
feelings which by the way is the
breakout hit that's it you gotta get
that new one we got about to drop is
real scandalous oh
yikes a little bit of a teaser we go
over our bank accounts and it's tax time
and someone's behind the eight ball
at least i got an eight ball hey listen
it's not me and toby
uh guys check it out and then obviously
we're on the road uh california l.a by
the time you're here this is probably
sold out um how about that los angeles
california thank you love you thank you
for all the all the cali's buying
tickets but [ __ ] scoop them up now so
you're not left out in the same friend
la jolla let's [ __ ] go i got a big
bowl of chipino on my mind when i get up
there yeah
continue that's it what do you mean we
just plugged the [ __ ] out of the dates
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
he's real lippy in the comments to have
been at each other's throats all day
i love that i'm out just watching by the
way i'm not saying for certain but word
is there's some video evidence out the
video evidence out there of some
poserness
from somebody i'm gonna cut that
he's so scared of it t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen everybody what's up what's
up t-bone yet another foleyville spin
zone we have a lovely drive-in we're
listening to van morrison we're talking
about how great that new john c riley
basketball
then you start bitching at me on [ __ ]
38th street about 39th street about how
i'm on twitter on the car we're stopped
in traffic
the car was moving and this guy's
reading about it yeah he freaked out
yeah you got no room to take break at
green light yeah
you do stink you're driving that's not
true it's yours
which which is a danger to everybody
else on the street but the only guy will
be doing 45 down 2nd avenue and you
[ __ ] pull the i'll tell you what
green light i'll tell you one thing
though just in case someone's coming one
thing that'll never happen to me as a
driver i'll never be involved in like a
90 car pileup yeah just 87 rear end
accidents
what happens behind me is their problem
but i wouldn't because you see people
driving down the highway you're like we
can't believe this happened yeah
everyone's doing 45 there's [ __ ] two
feet of snow on the ground we're not
talking about that we're talking about
sunny day no [ __ ] water on the ground
and you're stopping at green lights
that's craziness you like
you almost come to a complete stop at
green lights that's how they carjack you
that's how they t-bone you that's how
they carjack you sometimes no they don't
yeah they do they wait until it turns
green then they jump on you what and
their carjackings have been up because i
got these gas braces going through the
roof
yeah why fill it up with just steal a
car
i'm not going to wait at the bump
like a jerk off steal a corolla with a
family in it
[Laughter]
toby if you carjacked the car
and you got down the block and it had a
baby in it would you let the baby out
i'd raise it as my own
teach it how to steal cars yeah
get that thing a skateboard tootsuite
[Laughter]
use a little bastard as my grease man
yeah
put them in the vents
this is my son toby jr
we go town to town doing kick flips
not getting haircuts he's an ollie man
we're here it's good to see you boys i
love yous both
butter me up for something well i tried
to get you to pay for my haircut but you
said you won't
listen it's yeah it's not me paying for
it's not my it's our money i just tell
you write my head around that i just
tell you when you can and can't use it i
feel like somebody else pays that bill i
don't know because i never see it that's
free money to me that gold card
yeah well i mean wait till we got to pay
that thing this month it is hefty
and well listen we ain't we ain't that
liquid either it's taxis and i had to
file an extension
in blood
i gave him my pinky toe i said i'll send
the rest to send the rest around august
before my birthday you said you said
your ear let him know you mean business
why would he cut his ear
i don't know the guy's crazy just give
me the extension yeah just [ __ ] get
it i'll see you
patty one what was that there's a
there's a mask behind there okay who's
still wearing masks by the way i do
[ __ ] nancy pelosi in an uber
and you jam me up now i gotta take a
picture of myself and send it to every
uber driver like i'm trying to [ __ ] him
[Laughter]
that drop your star rating a little bit
i don't know yeah you're in the toilet
now
i get all the shitty cars come pick me
up
it's like a dude on a motorcycle it's a
city bus
three more stops and i'm at your place
thank you toby uh
appreciate wow that's good knock
everything out
he looks extra scruffy today folks you
can't tell it looks like you did wash
your hair t-bone i'll give you that
in the river
a couple of a couple of night crawlers
in there they're talking pretty tough
for a guy maternity pants
these are not easier these are
lululemons
these are lululemon pound cakes
hey those are my nice pair of
lemoncellos
yo these are my poo poo lemons
by lululemon meringues
like poo-poo lemons you're just [ __ ]
them
the [ __ ] just disappeared
new poop of lettuce it whisks the [ __ ]
right off your body now these are my
these are my good workout pants my good
job hey award at work that doesn't make
any sense i'm going straight to the
[ __ ] gym right after this
friday night where are you going to be
huh some pizza parlor with your buddies
not me i'll be lying right to my
trainer's face
i'm gonna be trying to be pulling the
wool over some poor guy's eyes in
astoria what are you talking about
straight to the gym i said
yeah and lie to that man to do that
and bamboozle a poor 28 year old jim's
his coke dealer
going straight to the gym
nothing of that
and the hindenburg went down ladies and
gentlemen oh the humanity
we're having a good time patty had a
question paddy's
can i hold 20.
she needs a payday loan
a pdl
that's pretty good i think straightened
out with the va um
she had a question sure it's mild
but then i have more of a confession
something that i have to tell you which
i really shouldn't say in a public
episode okay but i'm gonna anyway all
right for the sake of the broadcast okay
we gotta yeah we gotta move some tickets
let's do it
he's a victim of her own success i know
shit's gonna get weirder
i'll be [ __ ] my cousin in a couple of
weeks just to keep the lights on
next patreon bonus
[ __ ] my cousin eric
um
silverware in the dishwasher should it
go right side up or upside down uh
oh this is big is it
i have a couple of working theories on
this okay well forks don't fit upside
down
what do you mean jam them in oh do you
have a thing that opens up like the
whole oh the the open top tray i see
what you're saying okay the one i have
now has like slits that you stick in and
they stick up i'm talking about the
dishwasher i understand you have a
dishwasher yeah you do yeah what the
[ __ ] and i can't get a goddamn haircut
you believe this [ __ ] guy
why did this happen
we've talked about me having a
dishwasher dishwasher yeah oh look at
you
i told you i have a nice building way
nicer than what you know that rat's nest
out there in a story you're living in
i'm in the city i'm a city guy where you
stop manhattan
listen yeah so my current dishwasher
yeah that i loaded this morning yeah
with your underwear
you know the only difference between a
dishwasher and your mom
i
can't do it she listens
she knows it's a joke
it's a harsh one though man
uh one's easier to load
i don't know
your mom doesn't follow me my dishwasher
doesn't follow me around when i put a
load in it yeah
[Laughter]
folks that's a good piece of business i
don't care who you are
i think it was washing machine
originally but i'm crying dude i got the
giggies blow up my phone
and yes we could put them in any way we
want they have enough to one of my moms
yeah mine's more compact than because
they're going gonna steady
mine's more compact obviously my mom's
at yeah and my wife puts everything
facing up and i understand not even even
sharp knives and i cut myself every
[ __ ] time
you gotta put them down it's a safety
concern we can't do that at our house
for the dog cause the dog does a little
pre-wash if you must know what yeah wait
hold on
you you're
your dog licks all the dishes before
they go in yeah i am never she licks all
the dishes in the dishwasher while i'm
loading it
get daisy get there
take it yeah yeah and she just comes
back so you can't put a steak knife in
there that
dumb broth will [ __ ] rip her tongue
yeah and she's little baby can't have
that happen sure
but yeah i think i'm pretty sure that
was a booger that was just on my soul
and i was this is how bad it is [ __ ]
working with you i was hoping you were
picking a scab
i was i was placing all my eggs in this
scab it could have been some elmer's
some glue from what what were you gluing
not in 25 minutes
stuff sticks dawg always a good time
putting elmer's on your hand and then
peeling it off of course yeah oh i'm
sorry i did that real quick has the it's
not a booger it's glue has that ever
worked i have a feeling it worked like
once in 1984 and you've been running
that ever since hey because something
works with you
art class it's glue i swear
you're not even a real teacher
give me another box of macaroni well
yeah
i'm picking up that day this time
keep them coming
man i never got that even as a kid i was
like what the [ __ ] is this what making
[ __ ] with macaroni oh no [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he's just perfectly good food
[Laughter]
i just could never do watercolors there
was kids that would kill him
they're scraping glue off throwing them
into the pot one by one
don't worry about that glitter it'll be
all right
[Laughter]
i didn't get that [ __ ] at all i thought
that was whack yeah all arts and crafts
i thought was beat
i remember the thing that was a lot of
fun was making those bought the shoe box
the the dioramas with like a little
scene inside
yeah that was awesome you put the thing
up like you know like sideways like that
and then it's like 3d you build it i
remember blew my [ __ ] mind the
dioramas phantom will make a little
scene make the scene well in i remember
i was in like second or third grade you
had a we got like an animal and you had
to make that habitat like you know a
cheetah or whatever in the jungle yeah
yeah
and someone for like water
put a mirror down like you would like be
able to and i was like what the [ __ ] i
was like yo mom what the [ __ ] are you
doing
just having me color the cardboard with
[ __ ] blue i'm like these people got
[ __ ] up as a dead bird
i shot this in the backyard
[Laughter]
that was big those die that was fun i
like that i i could draw a little bit i
was in a little bit of a drawer really
yeah it was a little come on i'm telling
you still life what are we talking about
still life we're all right
you could do the fruit shout out to miss
lucente yeah you got any evidence of
this back at the house in a in the crawl
space somewhere i doubt it i doubt it we
sold it all it was worth a pretty penny
back in the day that's a kippy
that's the early stuff i got a question
for you i'm listening do you or anyone
in your family pronounce it drawing no
that's tough drawing
yeah i got plenty drawing i got a couple
people which is bad he can draw instead
of karaoke it's karaoke
[Laughter]
it's like a new version of karate
[ __ ] doing karaoke yeah they're
down there doing karaoke and i was like
what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah and i'm like yeah you know
it's karaoke croaky
a lot that's the same person does monday
tuesday wednesday
sunday yeah i'm pretty sure most of my
family says italy italy yeah yeah
italians little italy
it's the italians yeah they don't call
them that
to move on from here
don't get anybody in trouble
uh we remember just making ashtrays
oh with like pot or with like uh
play-doh we're not playing no you take
it back to the kiln we'd fire [ __ ] yeah
we had that for a minute what i'm
telling you shady grove we [ __ ] had
that shady that's first of all it sounds
like a retirement home or something like
that shady grove estates
but you check him but can never leave
you can check out but never leave shady
grove was weird that we had a mahjong
team
shady gro that was your elementary
school shady grove elementary shout out
to it skip back pike
it's shady grove yeah in the mornings we
do pickpocketing
at lunch we go under the bridge
and then an afternoon we're running
liquor
that was the first time that uh a
teacher ever made me for being fat
not not the last time either
i had one of those uh hostess pies
you know what i'm talking about they
were they were eclairs they were huge
they were like this big kind of yeah and
we had snack time that was still when
you got snack time you got snack time
and a lunch and at snack i was crushing
one of those in a high c ecto cooler and
i hear her go that's not a snack that's
a lunch i was like
[ __ ] blowing on my spot you dumb
[ __ ]
what are you doing i'm sitting here
trying to relax have a good time before
i play before i play foursquare
shouldn't you be out back catching a
smoke and calling your divorce lawyer
[ __ ] you're a teacher at shady grove
give me some lip
let's talk about bumbus
for the third time talking about bumbus
baby
bombas bomba's mission is simple gang
make the most comfortable clothes ever
and match every item sold with an equal
item donated yes look at that they're
giving it away so when you buy bumbus
you're also giving back to somebody in
need yeah and that's nice yeah bulma's
designed their sock shirts underwear to
be clothes that you can't wait to put on
every day everything they make is soft
seamless tagless
has a luxurious cozy feel and if you
know anything about the old kipperino
i'm big into luxurious field uh they're
maybe i don't know why you're
look at me like a snake they made from
super soft materials like mourinho
merino wool pima cotton and even
dan marino
you got dan marino these guys are all
right
joey marilina
that's a deep cut what's the philly
gangster really pops joey merlino
so go to bomas.com garbage and get 20
off your first purchase that's bomba's
b-o-m-b-a
dot com slash garbage for 20 percent off
bombas.com garbage do it do it hello
fresh hello fresh hello
fresh hello fresh you know it love it i
know it the foley family loves it's not
only just a spokesman but also a client
clientele patty's been gnashing on hello
fresh for the last couple of months down
here courtesy of old uncle hank yeah
bird likes a free meal that one yeah
she's a free bird she likes it hello
fresh is fantastic guys they really
really are we love them everything comes
pre-portioned you got nice ingredients
farm fresh ingredients that you cook up
right there you're saving yourself time
you're saving yourself money and here's
the thing too what's that this isn't a
part of the copy you're cooking things
that you normally wouldn't cook i don't
care who you think you are yes it's you
know you're doing spaghetti and
meatballs you're doing meatloaf you're
doing this you're not thinking of doing
cajun shrimp over a kale caesar or this
or that they send you all these cool
things that you would spend 45 minutes
looking around the grocery store for yes
and then you have a whole bushel of it
when all you need is a little bit for
the rest yes it's easy peasy the biggest
thing to do hello fresh cuts back on
time spent in the kitchen with meals
ready in around 30 minutes or less look
at that plus quick and easy meals
including 20 minute recipes and low prep
easy clean up options provide an even
faster route to putting food on the
table hello fresh is 72 percent cheaper
than a restaurant meal holy heck of the
same quality and you can save on average
65 a month when you order hello fresh
instead of grocery shopping uh that's
money right back in your pack in your
packet free and clearly so go to
hellofresh.com garbage16 and use promo
code garbage16 for up to 16 free meals
and three free gifts go to that's
broncos go to hellofresh.com
slash garbage 16 use code garbage save
for 16 free meals and three free gifts
do it do it
hello fresh hello fresh america's number
one meal kit do it no we had a semester
in art class where we were gonna say a
semester abroad
we went to
mexico learn how the coyotes work went
to tijuana for the weekend um no we had
a semester where we were like making
pottery and we would paint it and then
like put it put that gloss on it that
picture that scene and ghost with you
and the teacher
isn't it ghost
or dirty dancing what's this pie all
over me
that would get you a little noodle that
was that was very sensual demi moore
what are you out of your [ __ ] mind
was it demi it was debbie moore and
swayze right he was nothing to shake his
stick wasn't he dead in that
something he wasn't alive yeah he was
dead when they were doing that scene
nice to talk about the sixth sense
talk about the four and a half cents boy
that's what i call a poltergeist
um
the judges would have also accepted the
69th century ah
i thought four and a half talking about
my little pee pee was good the four and
a half seconds you would think yeah yeah
she was they they were both tight back
all right three and a half
quit lying nice coffee
you're not fooling anybody kevin
all right
this is a wacky one we're having today
anyway it's the first time we've seen
each other in a couple of days uh back
to the dishwasher
or do we wrap that up
yeah i think you always go
damn i think you always go down to be
safe think you're supposed to go up for
cleanliness though
right yeah it gets in there it gets in
there it gets everywhere the heat melts
it off yeah it's like re-entering the
atmosphere i remember in the 80s there
was no such thing i mean we put whole
plates of spaghetti in there
and the [ __ ] would just come out clean
oh no we were always pre-wat we have to
pre-wash really i still will i still
will hit it with a sponge get the yolk
off the hot sauce i used to put pots
pans anything in there yeah i don't do
that she didn't know what was that's my
ocd i got i gotta i gotta take it uh
even as a kid mm-hmm jesus that denise
runs a tight ship when it came to my fun
time at sleepovers with you huh and it
came to [ __ ] dish time
here's the scoop i think suck more than
busting the table as a kid
oh it felt like it was it was like i'm
like what are you guys like 20 years
hard labor you know i just had a nice
meal [ __ ] butters every time i turn
around there's more butter on the table
oh that sucks you get the plates and you
got to go get the napkins and the
[ __ ] salt and pepper shaker and this
is always a fight oh you don't even have
salad [ __ ] take your own chip
back yeah what is this a sitcom yeah uh
yeah it was always a fight
you do it [ __ ] you you do it screaming
at each other me and my brother
terrible kids um
speaking of terrible things like i said
i should keep this i shouldn't be saying
this publicly embarrassing
i'm peeing in the shower
not in the shower not in the shower
i'm going into the bathroom i'm turning
the water on
opening the curtain real quietly peeing
and then just hitting the water in the
tub
and this is a fat thing
it's not a f i mean oh it's because you
can't pee comfortably at the regular
toilet i can do it comfortably i just i
i'm i'm a wild shot
yeah but you do to the weight
so you've gotten to the point where
you're no longer using the toilet
think about that that's what you just
that's how i process that statement it's
just i'm supposed to be like that's
trash it's just easier to walk in there
and just pee in the shower yeah it's
also
easier to get
somebody backed me up on this somewhere
you're gonna get cut out of that house
at some point for sure
[Laughter]
it's easier than walking through the
doors
it's not a fan thing the doors just hurt
when i go through them so i took the
wall out
yeah that's not good that's not good
right that's not sanitary uh
[ __ ] all the other stuff to me
that's just like
your role
this is very [ __ ] patreon
that to me is full preview you're giving
up
to me
yeah you're going oh instead of
trying you're just making everything
easier rather than tr not saying you're
not trying to lose weight but you're
just going i pee in the bathtub now
that's silly and wacky and zany what do
i'm dumping in there i'm sure some of
those dudes were dumping in there what
dude where were those guys dumping the
guys that are like on the bed that they
had to get pulled out of the house oh
bedpans and stuff they're not getting up
to go to the bathroom
they're [ __ ] letting it ripped out of
you
this kid's got the right idea
yeah
stop doing that force yourself to
[ __ ] bend because it's laziness you
don't want to bend down and clean that's
what it is laziness yeah you don't want
to bet because you're
a larger gentleman
so you don't want to bend down and pick
it up
yeah well at some point you're like yeah
i'm just barefoot now dude the shoes
just really they're hot on my feet or
whatever why is that i wonder what the
steps are to that what what are my stuff
let's not look them up what are my steps
to fatness of to being bed written
shoes i've ran this scenario a lot i'm a
scenario kind of guy you're one knee
injury away from 900 pounds yes it's
that's and that's you know we i think we
might have 900
nobody lives to be 900 right
oh yeah my 600 pound life ooh
it's like yoda
you're not that far from uh score one
score with those broadsides uh you're um
the 1200 pound sisters or what they're
called the thousand pound gals
i can still see my little noodle i
i see a little guy he's in there
that's me you know i'm still here
you gotta get he gotta get it you gotta
lure him in like a squirrel
i have an elaborate series of mirrors
that allows me to do so
it's like the riddler's house
i go to the riddler too much but i love
the character uh
yeah i think an injury you're bedridden
one knee yeah
blow an ankle something a hip
a hip i think you're down for hips you
gotta get replaced you fall you slip on
ice or something my biggest fear i'm
gonna fold your knee goes and then
you're gonna be uh uh the size of a
house blow up from there yeah blow up
like the world trade unless i get on
unless i get heavy on the uh painkillers
i could could turn it around
what could all work out
no go heavy on the pills and slim up
yeah i come out of it
then i hang on halfway there
yes actually let's explore that route
let's see if the trainer [ __ ] signs
off on that one toby go get me a
baseball bat will you
[ __ ] tanya harding this guy
tanya harding myself ah
anyway those are the two things that i
wanted to bring up with you the
dishwasher in that yeah it's trashy no
good yeah yeah great she doesn't know
about it
she's not a fan of the show either i
presume no she is she checks in she
checks in checks to make sure the
[ __ ] numbies are there and keeps it
moving something like this might loop
back around on her radar
[Laughter]
okay
because i go through the whole song and
dance i flush the toilet i will even
turn the thing on that's that's how
insane that yeah i would this would have
been a perfect hard feelings to dive
into that's how insane you are you fake
it you're like i'm shaving i'm brushing
my teeth i'm you know yeah i'm rehanging
the
to the curt the shower curtain and the
[ __ ] towel racks i hate those things
they always come off what the shower
curtains because everyone's got to have
the fancy hooks now
not the clippy ones remember the
remember the old clippy ones
clip now do you have two or just one
for uh we talked about it when i was
i we just had one now we have two
liner yeah i don't like what they've
done with shower curtains
yeah
just saying not a fan
like it wasn't they were thin back then
you got one on the outside with a fish
on it or something like that
neither too down the shore or a mermaid
or something
yeah but we just talked about i like
drying i use it to dry my hands if the
towel's not there sure
sort of wipe my ass
kidding me
let it hang there
your poor shower mark my turf yeah what
do we got gang let's get to some cues
here okay all right did you know you
signed up for your patreon you get your
question read on the air on air by two
professional experts yes in the field in
the field of being dirtbags yeah
um
this one this is from joe new irish bozo
here haven't had one read yet welcome
lad have you ever scraped the butter off
the knife back into the tub after making
toast
scrape the butter off the knife
like there's like you know a little bit
of uh
shrapnel on there
right on the edge and all the crumbs
i had a big thing if there was crumbs in
the we were a prom or a margin uh
margarine margarine margarine which is
insane
that's what i know butter as that's
crazy i would take margarine over
anything because
you can't that's just cutting corners
denise
i mean really
save the money somewhere and margerine
yeah you took it to containers though
man nothing wrong with that strapped to
the gills with them promise containers
you don't know what's in oh man [ __ ]
turkey gravy and [ __ ]
yeah i remember wandering almost made me
i don't know i i was just so looking to
like butter my roll or whatever i had
going on and there was like some roasted
teeth in there the roast beef stew or
something i like gagged i was like seven
dude i was like [ __ ] this i thought it
was just never trud never trusted a
promised container ever again it was the
perfect like weight and stuff oh it was
bad
that's awesome i found a couple of
meatballs in there though yikes
but i never got and now like i'm a
butter man you know uh but you i don't
know buttermilk i'm about a man you
can't spread the butter the pat like you
the that's why i like the margarine
it didn't matter how cold the fridge was
getting nice
yeah yeah but then
there was a lot of crumbs in the in the
promise container yeah we went through
i'll be we went through a face sitting
here judging me and my [ __ ] single
mother's country crop trying to make
ends meet
country docks what country croc
here's how he rolled he stepped over
that uh
[Laughter]
you're a nice lady denise good thing you
don't know how to work the internet next
um
country croc melts too thin
you can't cook with it now it's very
it did i didn't know margarine wasn't
butter i thought it was i thought it
would turn into another molecular
substance it's not great it's very
chemically yeah weird hey i am what i
sold it on maybe that's why my head's so
big those two people you couldn't
he's got margarine head
this boy's been country cropped
lucie get me a muffin
i'm trying to chop some of this up
i'm gonna be the poster child to sue big
margarine i'm gonna be on like the
infomercials have you did you eat margin
grown up does your kid look like this
and it's just me is your forehead more
than three feet
uh that was great this one is 1400 on my
s.a.t which is a home run of a name
uh i don't know what it was out of are
you garbage if you think doing bicep
curls with grocery bags is exercise
liver king of you dude as a kid i was
[ __ ] i thought i was just you yeah if
you think the milk in it dude i was
[ __ ] bulking up for [ __ ]
pre-season dude
taking pre-workout two things a diet ice
tank
the big jugs of gatorade doing the iron
cross just love things
love those big jugs of gatorade yeah i
would drink a whole one of them uh-huh
going to football practice you get a
whole one whole big [ __ ] banger
at the turkey hoogie
before [ __ ] football practice
no we were doing two a days i get that
for lunch oh okay turkey huge coach is
screaming at you fat ass that's just
ain't a snack that's alert
it was snack time god damn it
now hit the showers with no pissing in
there either
he's got a napkin tucked into the
neckline of his jersey coach but my
party tray
a promise container full of meatballs
those are my meatballs god damn it
hang on there coach i'll be right back
the delivery driver pulls up you run
over
[Laughter]
anybody got a 10 on
anybody know it's been more than 30
minutes give me shoot me straight
it is we all eat for free today boys
his helmet full of ice cream
like at baseball games yeah but
it's the full-time
you're standing in line at the snack bar
in your uniform
where the hell is henry
hey man wrap it up
i got work to do
now turkey turkey classic from wow
that's what i got every day my head
hurts dude
everything wrapped in tinfoil
yeah everything
everything wrapped in tinfoil the cooler
was wrapped in tinfoil
now how much tinfoil we went through as
a kid
i know
i still hate those [ __ ] sandwich i
mean we've talked about it a bunch but
those sandwich bags the flip overs
that and so i can't wrap my head around
saran wrap stinks
it's like i try to use it dude
it's it's
like getting caught up in spider webs
i'm all wrapped up shit's everywhere
it's tough they don't have a good enough
a good enough cutter on the edge too i
know
you should hit you sound like a [ __ ]
blow torch
one of those things
yeah or that chopper they have the back
of the class the denogenizer
[Laughter]
that's a great goldman bit
they had the plastic scissors they
couldn't cut anything put in the back
they had a guillotine
it's like hey lady i'm 14. i can handle
the scissors
we got two kids beheading each other in
the back
shout out to gary gomez shout out to the
goals what are the best the best some
would say yeah keep up with those
fellows over there movement big fan of
the movement very similar i mean they're
doing a little bit better than we are
sure but they started out small a couple
of college dropouts bootstrapped it
bootstrapped it wanted to get in the old
sunglass business wanted to take on the
big boys yes and you know what they won
because now they do sunglasses they do
watches if you're not on movement.com
you got to go check it out it's [ __ ]
fantastic
it's it's it's high-priced stuff for a
fraction of the cost it's unbelievable
we got sunglasses we got watches we got
the whole schmear they're fantastic i
know i wear my i'm not a big watch guy
but you know they they gave us the
option i grabbed the watch and now i
wear it when i go out and i feel fancy
real fancy watches that look like a
quality like you know a 400 500 watch
that you're getting you'd pay at a
department store yeah fraction of the
price like 200 bucks you're out the door
uh-huh because they were built online
with their own process from start to
finish so they you know they're not
getting they're not robbing peter to pay
paul markups markdowns the whole nine
yards of taking it right to you get 150
dollar watch looks like it's just like a
500 watch it's crazy also my lady uses
the blue light lenses because she's at
the computer all day
yup
uh they're ever flipping away at it the
ever scroll blue light filtering glasses
are a game changer really helps with eye
strain poor sleeping patterns uh and
there's a modern style on the frames if
you want to elevate your look with style
that doesn't break the bank then join
movement and get 15 off today with free
shipping free returns by going to
mvmt.com
garbage again one more time take out a
pen write it down mvmt.com garbage do it
kim let's talk about coinbase coinbase
that's where all that's where i do all
my shopping talk about crypto
which we got a couple of bucks now gotta
wait your beak time to play the market a
little bit time
generational wealth i got enough money
in gold buzzwords i want to start
rolling the dice on the internet yes
coinbase is where to go uh coinbase
offers a trusted and easy to use
platform to buy sell and spend
cryptocurrencies look at that they
support most popular digital currencies
on the market and make them accessible
to everybody they even offer portfolio
management and protection there you go
learning resources and mobile not some
back alley deal where you're buying your
crypto now like a dirt bag yes come
inside the dark web this is this is
bright lights thousands of business on
the up and up i've been a user of
coinbase since i started dabbling in
crypto a couple of years ago millions of
people in over 100 countries trust
coinbase with their digital assets
whether you're looking to diversify
getting started or searching for a
better way to access
access crypto markets start today with
coinbase for a limited time
new users can get
10 in free bitcoin when you sign up at
coinbase.com garbage sign up at
coinbase.com garbage for ten dollars and
free bitcoin do it look at that
now back to the show back to the show uh
this is for mac's 10 homie here ever
taking a photo in the lobby of the hotel
you weren't staying in
i'm sure that happens a lot in vegas 100
because like that's like you know the
lobbies have the attraction the
fountains or the [ __ ] whatevers yeah
we've done that
i don't know if we've ever done one in
the lobby we weren't staying in
we stayed at my cousins
in dc
for easter
and we went around i mean there was like
30 of us like i'm talking a pack it's
when we rolled around in caravans be my
uncle mike's car my uncle joe's car my
dad's car somebody else's car [ __ ]
following each other around the
backwoods of [ __ ] virginia yeah it's
crazy um
we did that we'd go to we go to the
hotel and take a picture out front
do [ __ ] like that
it's tough yeah
as a fan we never like again we never
really went on vacation just because we
went to the shore all the time like that
was like we didn't go away during the
school year
and you didn't go away in the summer
this was easter
yeah we want to go down the shore for
easter we go everywhere down to shore
for east yeah
i always hated it but now as i get older
i like it yeah it's quieter you get a
way to hustle and bump you can't go
swimming though oh jump in the water
um
yeah so we never really did hold like
i've probably been on like [ __ ] three
hotels with my mom just standing hotel
as a kid with your parents was weird
especially if you weren't in the same
room
you don't know if i've ever real that's
what i'm saying i can't even really
remember ever doing it
i don't think the thought of like
standing in a lobby with my mom
waiting to get room keys is like crazy
really
i mean went to disney
once or twice
i don't remember you know but that was
it i don't know if you stayed at a house
or so
i don't i can't recall staying at
somebody's place on vacation is a tough
look no they would rent in the house
okay yeah yeah not like staying with
like somebody used to be the neighbors
uh the one though we did say was me my
brother my sister
in a room
okay
and then me and my brother would share
my sister would have a bed
okay
so legit was it a connector
what do you mean you never told me was
your guys room connected
in tampa we have still yet to get the
connecting doors so the hotel rooms are
palling around i don't think they do
that anymore
the last hotel we stayed in adam
i know because they opened the door
yeah they keep icing on i'm trying i'm
trying to pal around with the ball
around doors
sure i don't know i do none of the rooms
i've ever stopped that's how you do a
little freaky d and loyal listener my
promise to you is that the second we do
you gotta hear about it it's gonna be
great yeah you open the door and you
knock on the door next door
do three knocks
let them know you're in the party show
them the upside down pineapple
is that true did you ever hear that what
upside down pineapple yeah if you go to
someone's house for like a dinner
someone invites you over for dinner you
get there and there's like a lot the
upside down pineapple is the indication
for swingers really throw that in the
old uh google noodle it where is it
where is it like an actual project just
be sitting there and like no like a
picture or a painting or anything just
the visual of an upside down pineapple
huh
we've been seeing it on that tick tock
really the upside down pineapple oh yeah
these kids are doing weird [ __ ]
naughty okay this is
oh man it's even more specific than what
you're saying
it's it's cruise ship swinger [ __ ]
so if you see a pineapple on a door on a
cruise ship it means that the
couple inside is down to clown and
probably gross as [ __ ] yeah
that's never too hot
the thing no that was a t-bone zest
added to it i'm gross as [ __ ]
how you can all put [ __ ] on your hotel
room door like that like a magnet or
something you're bringing it they're
looking you know it's like power bait
do you also just look for the bald guy
with a ponytail yeah
or me
uh would i ever do something but swing
yeah no never
not your cup of tea i don't
i don't know who would benefit in that
situation at all
i wouldn't have fun i doubt she would
and then some guys with my wife who's i
don't understand anything
this isn't checking any boxes for me
all right
how about you i assume now what is this
your offering you just slide a pineapple
over time
pineapple upside down cake which aren't
bad by the way listen i know he's gross
and fat but if you [ __ ] him we'll give
you two first round draft picks next
to next year's swinger hall of fame who
are we banging the clippers what's going
on
no i'm not yeah
stays are behind me uh tired
all right this one's from joshua know
anyone that was born with teeth
i [ __ ] you not my two daughters we're
both both born with bottom teeth
that's power plant type [ __ ]
i don't
it's weird dude you put them immediately
up for adoption just chewing on nippies
think about that that's gonna that's
gonna make them bad boys rough
and the lord
is that's insane yeah i don't i mean no
one i know maybe i'm sure my family's so
big i'm sure somebody you know
born with a grill
[Laughter]
paul walsh where's the house cousin was
born with a tear drop that dude he won't
shaking his head no dude this is like
ripley's believe it or not [ __ ] really
cause it's not even that they're
prenatal teeth which is different from
natal tea which are your baby teeth sure
so it's like an extra set of creepier
baby teeth damn
it's dad's italian his mom's a great
white
that's crazy
three cents that's the most holy joke
ever
three sets of teeth
clean up with the tooth fair you know
yeah [ __ ] make 15 grand
that's a lot yikes both daughters he
says says i [ __ ] you not my two
daughters that's then genetic yeah
that's wild crazy um i just wants from
maggie first time long time is it
garbage to sleep on top of your
comforter and use a throw blanket to
sleep with so your bed is technically
always made
i don't know how you do it that sounds
insane yeah just don't make the best but
sleep in your clothes
just don't make the bed i don't me my
wife will make the bed from time to time
well there you go either way the
problem's getting solved but that's nuts
sleeping on your comforter like that i
would always if i ever fall asleep i
always end up taco in it
you make tacos in the middle no i take
the blanket and i i pull i pull it over
on me
so i'm in there like a little taco oh if
you fall asleep on top what happened to
false if yeah
pass out was the more correct term i was
all [ __ ] up woke up with a taco yeah
that's crazy yeah no no none of that
that's real trash at any point in your
life have you used a sleeping bag as a
duvet or comforter
pouch cover
couch cover
[Applause]
we know some people
who will be on the show quite soon
uh yeah no that's tough
yeah cause it doesn't fully it's warm
yeah it does it unzips completely no
no the one hinge always stays no no i
mean a little bit yeah they're pretty
cozy and they're water resistant for
your bed spills
uh i did have plastic accidents
and that monitor yeah that's no good
because about the bed
you're not
like you're not like you're doing that
to be a responsible person whatever
that's not being you're cheating the
system there
you got to make you got to actually make
the bed sure that's the thing is is and
i believe me i could never have that
kind of discipline i don't understand
the making of the bed but i'm also i
know people like to start your day off
you've completed a test it looks it
makes the room look so much better good
i'm not gonna i'm not in the room until
i [ __ ] go back to sleep so now i got
to do more work together that's a mental
thing i'm doing mentally fine start
sleeping on the comforter in like a
psycho
why oh i just don't like the bed that's
what i said yeah [ __ ] it that's what i'm
saying i like having a messy bed sure i
like having a sleeping bag as a
comforter
we had bad sleeping bags growing up we
didn't have good sleeping bags
one that we shared people had the nice
satin on the outside and the like the
flannel on the inside ours was the thing
on the outside all around oh
yeah man yeah it was not good that's
sweaty it's like sleeping in chinese
finger cuffs yeah
it's it was sad um
it didn't roll up right like it didn't
stand by me i was old yeah that was the
hardest part of the rolling it up as
like an eight-year-old yeah your brain
and hands couldn't do it and i would
just be like dragging her through the
front yard going home from a sleepover
or whatever that thing must have stopped
oh yeah
i never [ __ ] fart since i've never
like getting in it it's too [ __ ] i
feel like i'm in a coffin i can't do it
i'd rather you ever camp out in your
backyard
we tried and we were in by like you know
10 15.
as soon as you heard that first owl yeah
the coyotes came lurking kippy
well the one time i was really young my
brother and cousins were doing it who
were like you know they might have been
[ __ ] ten or something so i was
probably like five or six or whatever
and i wasn't allowed to they were like
you you know my parents my mom's like
you're not you're [ __ ] sick you're
not staying out with and i mean these
[ __ ] kids are probably smoking and
drinking already
they were like what 13 no like 10 or
something okay
or maybe 11 or whatever so my mom's like
you're too young to stay out so i was
gonna stay till like you know until
bedtime and then have to go in
pansy i was
uh but then they didn't make it all
night yeah that was slim fast
i clear my head
hey guys
all right looks like we head up the
wooden hill grab my slim fast and my bag
of hers nibblers and call it a [ __ ]
night golden girls are starting in ten
minutes so you gentlemen will excuse me
uh
yeah and then we did it once on my
buddies just to drink
like 16. sure
and then still just went inside like we
just drank outside and then we're like
it was [ __ ] freezing we
way underestimated it
we're like i'm like dude let's just
[ __ ] go inside it's like 11 30. we're
drunk it's freezing like what are we
doing we just went in and slept on the
couch what about you hillbilly no but i
did go on camping trips with my family
outdoor camping yeah with just your
family yeah it was awful it rained the
whole time
if you're like woodsy people like if
your dad hunts if you do that kind of
like yellowstone yeah you went out yeah
your dad was like an art professor or
something like that he had no business
being out in the wilderness that's
blatantly irresponsible i know it could
have got you real hen you already freeze
to death out there
they always find one or two of them here
well no some family you [ __ ] went the
wrong way well if we got chased by a
bear or something like that he could
handle it you know start creating term
papers
what would you take would you take like
a little like a little camper
no we would go like campsite
like in a regular that's always weird
a regular car
pull up in a taurus and then hop out and
no you need a jeep or a wagoneer or
something something that looks the part
at least putting a tent down in a
parking lot it's no good dude you're
just tailgating in the woods
if you're going to a campsite
we did a camper
i've said my stepdad
he's a woodsy guy though hillbillies
yeah rednecks these people
they would do it he's fired a weapon
before oh yeah bow and arrow
he's pulled it on some family members
my brother
snuck in one night from out boozing nice
i didn't know my sister
he was something happened i forgot the
whole story yeah some nickels but what
the [ __ ] is that he'll get this [ __ ]
he was about to regulate any piece of
steel up on that property uh a couple of
warning shots and his little whitey
tighties and my brother's like it's me
it's me my mom's like they didn't even
even know there's a gun in the house
he's like where the [ __ ] did that come
from he's got to [ __ ] snub that two
m16s
calling in a drone strike
um
he's up there with the [ __ ]
night vision goggles on in his underwear
yelling clear throwing flash bangs
those are my biggest fear um flashbang
for when i don't know
whenever they whenever they hit whenever
the hammer comes down
but you would assume that's the way
you'd want to go if they ever come to
get me
i want it to be like that who's they i
don't know
but they got hangers they're not gonna
need hand grenades and flashbangs to get
you just put a cheeseburger in a box
with a [ __ ] with a stick on it
the rest is history what's that pickles
they can't get me
no but that's always my fears is it was
one of those getting thrown in a window
out of nowhere like that window right
there it's also
then you know that's when you know it
the jig's up no you gotta grab it and
throw it back out
that's the move you don't just sit there
what if it goes off in my hand well it's
going off anyway
right that's you have to tell they got
hemmed up in the town someone's gotta
make that move
but you jump on it i don't jump when you
get it the [ __ ] if you there's an open
window you [ __ ] toss it back at them
that's the move they'd be real pissed
about how would it be well-received
now he just made a man
the queen's county sheriff's office
doesn't take kindly to that kind of [ __ ]
no but that's always imagine how it
going down yeah you keep saying that i
don't know what you mean i don't know
are you thinking about them coming to
get you
what i know you do
who who are they know
i don't think about anybody coming to
get me
yeah me neither i do get nervous going
into banks but other than that that's
not involving you what do you mean you'd
be caught up in it
you get nervous no i'm nervous
then i'm gonna get in there and they're
gonna be like sir
you haven't paid your taxes in 75 years
you owe us i'm afraid of financial ruin
ah
i'm afraid like that thing like that
dream you have where you wake up and
you're like oh
you're in school like a test today like
that
like how did i forget the term paper was
due i have that feeling that like all of
the money is gonna get pulled away any
time that i've been in a bank
cashing a check depositing a check
and they've gone
wait right here give me one second and
left
my if it's taking more than 15 seconds
my inkling is to sprint out of the bank
but i haven't done anything wrong i'm
just cashing a check like a regular
[ __ ] like a regular working joe
cash and checks is a tough look oh man
the pot yo the gentleman deposits the
check i've cashed one
pretty recently i've cashed one within
the last
eight months whoa yeah a commercial i
did
remember the e-check
oh they sent me a [ __ ] e-check
i didn't know what to do i tried to
deposit into my navy federal account
they were like guyer
they weren't having it take your
treasures elsewhere
there'll be no quarter here
so i had to go to [ __ ] chase chase
bank i remember the timing of it
it was a little dicey i was there at 9
00 a.m yeah i remember you were trying i
remember this yeah you're you're very
whatever problems going on in your world
is everybody else's around you's issue
sure
sure if you need a village to raise a
foley
if you need to check
if you're a little tight you defeat them
am i right
all right if you're a little tight on
cash
you've ran the scenario by t but you
don't think they're gonna seize my
account if uh like you run through and
you go to everybody that you see that
day
for advice but if i go to you
that means you hold some sway with me
so first of all i of course i [ __ ]
should some crap that's not saying much
but yeah also
i mean i have my pro my personal
problems don't become your problems
what can i do i'm not making worse what
i make them worse i know
yeah
yeah lean on you a little bit a little
bit what are you gonna do listen i'm
just saying if i deposit a check at 502
do you think the financial institute i
don't [ __ ] know stop being a scumbag
and get there during regular business
hours all right well if i do it on my
phone it's technically registered as
come on you make too much money to be
cash and checks anymore eight months ago
i didn't pretty much i was on a very
thin thin wire yeah
there was a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of ball in the cup action over
there barely got this thing off the
ground
like the dude that bought the islanders
everything checked out if you have not
seen that 30 for 30 do yourself a favor
and go check it out mm-hmm guy who tries
to buy the islanders it's serious
um all right let's let's scoot through a
couple of moe here please um
uh
this is from scott never had a question
read have you ever ordered your own
birthday cake
no
i would hope not that's sad
ordered your own birthday cake
let me ask you this you're an office guy
i've never really been an office guy
sure uh not the program um
for the record it was a chuckle toby uh
i was thinking of my own joke in my head
and i'm a big fan
i workshopped it ran it by uh did some
market research everybody's a fan i
think it's something the other day
if you if it's your birthday that's
something i said earlier
[Laughter]
just laughing at something i thought if
it's your birthday at the office is it
your job to bring in cupcakes for
everybody listen what's the rule with
that i was very anti-social in the
office i never went down for a happy
birthday you never went down for a hap
really i went when you're one of the
somebody was retiring and i got lumped
in
i figured out when everybody was taking
their breaks and when all that stuff
would be and i like staggered mine so i
was
out of i'd rather i was just out front
[ __ ] catching heaters
about six heaters in an hour ripping
darts trying to play with the books
having a chicken parm a couple of
[ __ ] stingers call it a day i'd
imagine you would operate in a cubicle
scenario like a like someone who's
scouted a bank heist where you like know
everyone's rotation so you can move
through without ever interacting with
anyone it was very don't look at me
don't talk to me he looks real weird and
business casual too let me tell you that
yeah
you always look you just got fired
i was very close a lot of times
so you didn't have to bring your own
cake in
it wasn't your responsibility to have a
birthday party
you know the off not you [ __ ] neo
relax no i think they might a lot of
places do
uh
you know like a month like hey
on the 15th we're gonna celebrate
everybody in june's birthday unless they
really like you if they really like you
like the partners and stuff they would
get the you know they would get a big
bigger to-do or like the people who were
like there for you know [ __ ] night
but in that situation it's not the
person whose birthday it is to bring it
in it's not elementary school yeah
because when you were a kid it was and
that's all i can tell you is not going
to be throwing you a birthday party
that's [ __ ] weird
taking the scores
because i remember that was always
tension at the folio i got to make these
cupcakes
yeah freaking out
you fat little bastard
[ __ ] cupcake drop him or something
like that
she'd freak the [ __ ] out yeah smell like
cigarettes so he got him
[Laughter]
man i got dropped off in a purple
intrepid with my stepmom smoking
blasting [ __ ] bob seeger's greatest
hits
[Laughter]
your parents dropped you off at school
with the radio blast and you are [ __ ]
straight trash turn their [ __ ] down all
right love you love you
[ __ ] turn that [ __ ] right back up
there was a lot of that a lot of that
and i'd get a dub on the way if my dad
was dropping me i get a dub on the way
out the door
that
we've come to realize we did not have
like hey
you might still have the house if you
weren't giving 20s away every day to the
kids at school that's how you live
though baby i know fast and loose that's
the way we do it only way we know how
new money um
no never bought my own cake
button plenty of cakes for other people
especially lately with the specific
intention of a face throw spent like 150
bucks on somebody's birthday cake
not that long ago
have you ever purchased an ice cream
cake not for a birthday
folks this episode is brought to you by
helix
that's a yes i mean
yeah probably all strung out needed the
sugar to keep the [ __ ] hands from
shaking uh happy birthday charlie can
you put on here
uh yes i have purchased the little
carvel johns that they have
at the grocery store at the end of the
aisle at the end of the aisle
yes as a substitute for ice cream like
instead of getting as a substitute for
breakfast
swap out the two eggs of bacon for a
little crunchy cookies and some fudge
swirl
um
in replace of getting
a half a gallon of ice cream
so i don't see it as that bad it is ice
cream at the end of the day
hey what is this russia what the [ __ ] i
mean
okay tell it to the judge fatty two
things i take issue in this and what you
just said one is the it's all fat moves
by the way one is called fat moves
a little too fat could have lose a few
pounds
eating ice cream cake that was a double
d side
uh
i you called it a little ice cream cake
which leads me to believe that it was
the biggest one available wow what are
you nuts
and you also said they don't key yeah
you had to get it delivered two guys
you throw it up like a couch and you
said instead of a half gallon of ice
cream which leads me to believe that you
were getting a giant tub of gerbert no
one with the handle on it
i don't think sherbet comes in that just
comes in a little little little sherbet
thing though
try to get that thing off
i still sell that sherbert [ __ ] yeah
okay they do
uh they do 100 but now we haven't done
the big tub of ice cream scouts early
80s yeah that was that was recession era
uh maybe in high school too to be honest
with you i was she was kicking in the
early 90s yeah she would rock that out
because it was you know by that time we
were like 15 16 the boys were coming
over yeah that and the big the gallon
jug of chocolate milk
that was it was like it was made with
pure butter it was so thick oh they
never did the pre-made oh all the
hershey's we had the hersheys
there was a stint
i'd say probably 89 to 94 where one of
those big ass [ __ ] chocolate milk
have you ever done the double chocolate
milk would you pre-made chocolate milk
and put syrup in it no because the two
chocolate flavorings never combined
together well i've
experimented but i never put anything
into production
it was strictly on the prototype level
you know they're the hair net in a
beaker
[Laughter]
the chocolate explodes in your face damn
it
now back to the drawing board did i ever
tell you the one
it seemed like most of the early
late 90s into the early 2000s
we were a super fresh family mm-hmm
um and which
i think went
either way depending on each location it
was a very nice location okay new
construction okay very nice location
there was a super fresh
right over there in norristown or east
norton
on germantown avenue that was
downtown beirut yeah it was stabby alley
yeah yeah no this one was very nice new
construction in like the [ __ ]
you know late 90s or whatever
very nice good time in those late 90s
but she was big on that uh
like the 10 for 10
or whatever they would do the deal of
like the yogurts was big on that but
but america's choice hershey sarah
america's choice was super fresh is bran
america's choice hershey syrup was 10
for 10 and she bought like 15. 10 for
10. yeah the [ __ ] like regular size
yeah because it's like pretty much brown
water she is so [ __ ] you know it's
like america's best i've never had
anything
never had anything from those [ __ ]
that was anything good now there's no
new hershey's coming in because we got
15 [ __ ] america's best and it takes
like six months to go through one of
those containers so for like six years
we just had this america's best and it
[ __ ] i remember like squirting it
down the sink and [ __ ] i was throwing
them in the woods in the back trying to
get rid of these [ __ ] things to get
back on the gravy train get back on the
good [ __ ] yeah it was bad i was like
what the [ __ ] every time there was a new
america i'm like what are we doing it's
like smoking ecuadorians at the cubanos
you know it was always good on paper but
never good in reality wait
ness quick
no that's what's great is it chocolate
milk related it's chocolate syrup
related
the bosco the shell no shell
hey guys relax i'm guessing that's
something that i thought i was gonna
guess wrong bozo i wasn't able to per
chick i wasn't able to purchase magic
shell until i was in there he just said
maybe one word correctly
i wasn't able to perk in mega chill
that's what i heard from you i was not
able to purchase magic shell until i was
well into 80 years
my mother looked at that like it was
titanium magic shell how many sees my id
it's locked up
hey you open the uh magic can i get two
magic shells next to the core of seeding
you gotta promise me you're not gonna
cook mac meth with it that stuff is
unbelievable we only did it once and it
was because like there was like a sunday
part like you know i think my sister
worked at a camp and there was like some
sort of sunday party and that made it
back to the house but we never she
she's buying america's best [ __ ]
serve 10 for 10. she's not going here
she's not pulling the shell out and i
think america's choice magic shows just
a sock or something it's just a just a
dress sock
plastic laid over it
um
we also never got i mean i feel like i
mentioned this recently
god i'm sorry
uh peanut butter and chocolate syrup
sandwich
it seems like it would be great never
good
you guys never tried that what white
bread peanut butter and chocolate syrup
i'm sure i've tried it
but yeah now
i can see that not going not going right
no
i'm actually shocked that neither of you
tried this i'm sure i have you know how
that would be good
may i may i may i spin this little magic
shell it's not all running no you would
have to you get a pan get a little bit
of butter
throw the [ __ ] uh
the peanut butter
uh piece of bread
bread it a little butter on the outside
grill it then put a little magic a
little chocolate sauce on it then put
the other piece of bread and flip it
make it like a grilled cheese then slice
it put it on a plate maybe a little
powdered sugar and then a little uh
chocolate drizzle on top
then you got an appetizer
then you got something to play with
that's not a snacky fat piece of [ __ ]
miss cooper
crushed me um let's do a couple of more
here uh this one is brendan my wife said
her favorite meat is ham yikes
i'm a big ham guy oh no all across the
board the big one the the the honeywell
or whatever it's called or is that the
air conditioning honeywell's an air
conditioning uh honey baked the honey
baked spirals i get the carrier those
things aren't cheap how much is a honey
baked ham by the way retail
is that what we're using the internet
for
yeah
welcome to the show what did ham close
at today
again that's a goldman bit
is it really yeah but is that when they
say market price he goes
excuse me what did shellfish close at
ah he's good stuff
love to get him in here i i just
messaged him
got nothing back goldman hit me up
scary you pull them aside you pull them
aside
[Laughter]
if you haven't jumped in to anything
that gary goldman does i mean
the best
it's shockingly difficult to pull up
honey baked ham prices are you what are
you nuts go to the [ __ ] website the
ham website
go to ham.com that's.org for sure use my
username and
password honey baked as a company
just go to amazon honey baked ham amazon
that's not good
that sounds like russian hacking to me
can't get a kick and a quote on ann
what's the deal
honeybaked.com it's got to be
honey baked ham
it's almost easter that's probably the
first thing that comes up
there's [ __ ] kids on screw balls
honey banked i do relax stop saying i'm
going to lose my mind with the spiral
swirl
oh my size oh maybe maybe it's spiraled
ham
maybe
google press tame
in a can no pressed ham is when you moon
someone and put your butt cheeks them
can't have that for dinner
all right ham is currently trading at 10
at ten dollars and 39 cents a pound
that's how much it is for a honey bake
ten ten dollars a hundred dollars or
something ten pound ham how many what
would you need to feed the family
tiger king i don't even like it
really ham and some scalloped potatoes
on easter with some like apple sauce i
don't do the ham i do the ham at
christmas just to appease my aunt who
makes it but ooh she makes a homemade
ham
damn i think so yeah and then yeah you
like [ __ ]
juice it the whole time with the
pineapples and stuff i don't [ __ ]
know i'm not in the kitchen taste sweet
dirty bird
you know what she's up to
no honey baked sprout ham delicious it
has like a sugary crust on it it's
fantastic so i respect that and when it
comes to lunch meat there really is no
substitute for a good ham and cheese i'm
a turkey and cheese you go turkey
because you want to watch listen you
can't be eating ham every day i get it
you got to go to turkey for that buffalo
chicken shout out to the [ __ ]
blaze and buffalo oh man the guy the
deli guys hate making it though because
it jams up that slicer real bad because
it falls apart so it's so tempting but
that the buffalo sauce gets all over
everything they gotta like break it down
and power wash it after each slice you
ever use a slicer like actually proper
use one
i don't think so okay
you know what i did for a while
i was working i worked at a butcher shop
and i would wrap meat that thing where
like you pull it and then you like
[ __ ] oh like wrap meat like like the
steaks yeah really you're like yeah and
you would [ __ ] pull it it was an art
and you have to like [ __ ]
use the weight of it to pull it were you
flipping them were you taking the
expiration date off and changing them
like they say they always do the expo
why why would i
say that on anywhere what are you
talking now this is an aboveboard
operation anytime the meat's brown you
know they flipped it a couple of times
started out as fillet now it's a t-bone
but i was so excited you know it's
hamburger yeah i was real [ __ ] bad at
it oh you have that heated pad that you
like sit you sear the [ __ ]
and i was getting there's an art to
wrapping up a sandwich the guys that can
do that really tight
yeah you know oh forgot it's a mess
eat it with a knife and a fork but when
i worked at robert's market in
wrightsville beach north carolina
uh we have a bragging right
weren't you supposed to be a movie star
or something at that during this time i
was researching a role
[Laughter]
every time you've ever mentioned north
carolina i was shooting a movie for four
months i didn't know you were bagging
groceries i didn't shoot anything i shot
one
heroin
i did one short film that's all that's
all we got it was a total bust it was it
was it was all we got it was a bad move
that's all i did like you went out to
hollywood and you're like i only got one
role we thought that was hollywood we
didn't know any better durham north
carolina yeah what was the town
wilmington wilmington where we are
johnny rockets
what was it called i worked at pusser's
landing
i worked at pusser's landing um east
coast landscape company
and i worked at robert's mark how long
were you down there like nine months you
had three jobs in nine months man you
are unemployable kept getting fired yeah
no [ __ ]
yeah also wait you've worked three jobs
and did a short film oh it's short film
was like a couple of days why did you
move to north carolina that's a weekend
i didn't move there to do the short film
we moved there to try to get into the
business down there they filmed dawson's
creek i was missing four hey hold on
you know this
i go to theater school uh okay hold on
this was what
this is what i thought let's back it up
a little bit i go to the state wrestling
tournament my senior year of high school
all right then i graduate bang the
cheerleader
i flunk out of college
i go to the hedgerow
okay we have to save this for patreon
okay goodnight everybody
real cold like that
i just fade to black
uh all right let's do one or two more
questions then we gotta get up and get
out of here okay this is from stormy is
it garbage to throw two popcorn bags in
the microwave how would you do that that
sounds insane to me
what do you put it on 500 i don't know
no how many minutes you put on because
let me tell you something there is no
more
situation in life that is a razor's edge
than microwave popcorn
i know the trick if you ever read the
directions
there's a trick i know it's a trick i
know what my trick is what i put it on
three minutes okay and then i sit there
and wait and once i hear it stop popping
i get it out of there well you're
probably you're probably even a little
too late i think it's i forget the exact
rule but i think it's three seconds
between pops okay pop
one two and then but then i'll sit there
and count because i'm like a [ __ ]
psychopath and i want to get it i want
to want to exactly hit that i like it
burnt sometimes
yeah toby no way okay
um there was a long time when thanks
buddy we didn't have a lot of stuff at
the house
snacks wasn't great when i would get
home from school
as like junior high or whatever burn it
it was more of like a high profile fluff
palette flavor i thought smokiness yeah
throw it in the traeger
little meat um but i would do a thing i
like orville redenbacher's [ __ ]
popcorn and then i found this [ __ ]
sprinkle cheese like nacho
like it was like a spice
kind of and it was like bright orange
dude i wear like the powder and like mac
and cheese
similar yeah hey you're making your own
cheese popcorn it was i tell you you
leave a fat kid in the 90s home alone
man it's either that or slim fast
they come up with we come up with
something yeah didn't matter what it was
put a little bit of that in there it's
probably nice because you know it
wouldn't be bad it's parmesan cheese a
little parm cheese on popcorn were you
proper parmesan cheese or are you the
[ __ ] craft green tub we were believe
it or not which i see how much it was it
blows me away we were the
the jaw the tub of like fresh the green
one oh yeah what was the green one craft
craft yeah we were that for a little
while but then we're still that when we
started getting to high school she
started going with la catella
locker town with la catella she gets it
over there at kerbaly's
yeah i don't know whose it is but i know
it's [ __ ] i see it up here it's like
10 bucks it ain't cheap yeah that's
where all our money's going
shake cheese
or upside down in it um
all right let's do this and we'll get
out of here uh well this is just uh
hold on to answer that question yeah
that's [ __ ] insane i don't know how
you would do that also who needs that
much popcorn
well i can understand that but you got
to do it once i'm saying if it's three
minutes throw one in for three minutes
it's not like i don't see how it would
work you can't put that in there for six
minutes and it's all gonna cook no i it
would have to be the same time it's not
it's
i think conv it's not convert microwaves
work in the sense of like there's two
different methods of cooking in the
sense of like regardless of the mass
that's in there i'm really juggling i'm
really jumbling this up
it's not like one because you sound like
you know exactly
it's not one to one it's dependent upon
so it's not like you put it in for six
minutes if it's three and three
right it's like a completely new it's
not two of the same thing it's a
completely new product right yeah so
like the rules for two doesn't mean one
i would say three or four minutes
probably yeah but they how would they
even fit in that's a big microwave i
just imagine like steven seagal like
snapping a guy's neck and then throwing
two bags of popcorn into a microwave and
then it cuts to him outside as the house
explodes
it's coming out the door
do you ever do the ones where you keep
it on the stove we gotta get out of here
did you ever do the one
buddy that was garen that was burn your
house down in the air that [ __ ] to me
might as well you might as well been
camping home on the range or something
we did we i mean that's this is i
remember i remember pre-microwave
popcorn that's why i was lawless you had
you had the popper
with the yellow
like visor on yeah the appliance which
wasn't bad but the jiffy pop it always
burned there was no butter on it it
tasted like wood chips it was just the
novelty of watching that thing get big
and watching the baby [ __ ] [ __ ] her
pants when [ __ ] she could ah i'm
freaking out
never worked out right yeah all right
just from mike peters then we gotta get
up and get out of here as someone you
know started a buy the bride to drink
venmo on a bachelorette weekend
i've seen that on the back of cars like
bachelorette party buy me a drink at
tugboat.org or whatever
that but i think i would do it just out
of wait somebody you don't know yeah why
not your [ __ ] mind i'm supporting a
good time i'm talking about people that
they don't know didn't we do weren't we
on something buy us a cup of coffee what
was that called
oh yeah we got a couple of bucks on that
what was that called coffee.com that's
what the name of this this is it was
kofi.com or something it was like a paid
direct to the performance it was a very
page it was like uh
a thing of patreon where like you could
it was before patreon or it wasn't
patreon not connected no it wasn't gonna
necessarily jack conte is coming up with
some dog [ __ ] idea like that
guy's a [ __ ] gentleman uh it was very
like uh we did it when we did hard
feelings originally
and because we didn't want to have to do
all of this
first of all nobody was listening to
that you know nobody's listening to the
podcast because nobody cared or whatever
so i was like i don't want to do
a whole nother episode each week for
like three people if four people joined
the patreon so coffee if you wanted
yours.com was this way it was like a tip
and you would go in so we would do like
for every
five cups of coffee we get
it was called buy us a beer so for every
beer that someone bought us for every
six beers
we would do a bonus episode that
everybody would get so it was like this
idea of like you could go like i'll buy
you a six-pack
yeah yeah that would get everybody in
episode communism a little bit yeah what
i mean hear that kids you gotta do a lot
of [ __ ] that doesn't work until you land
on gold yes
shout out to sam yam and jack conte and
we thank you and we love you and we
appreciate you
um yeah doing that i've had people
i've gotten things
like for
to buy wrap it up
i can't let this stand
i've gotten i've got a t-boner like i
think we're at 90 minutes i've i've
gotten things from like if a wedding's
coming up to buy that bride of beer
or something like that i i was hey get
the [ __ ] out of here buy buy your drink
help her cheat how to help her ruin the
wedding
and they're so [ __ ] up she [ __ ] her i
don't i don't mind it i you know if i
was in it had it in front of me and i
saw it and i had enough time to pull it
out and you know send
uh it's trish oh yeah for sure it's all
guard but i supported him
[ __ ] buying some [ __ ] i don't know
[ __ ] her and her [ __ ] fat friend's
a [ __ ] drink [ __ ] do i care
sure can't stand bachelor parties to
begin with yeah rune comedy shows room
nice dinners out you saying roon ruin
gang you ruined it
i ruined roon
gang we [ __ ] love you to death we
appreciate it
get those tickies like we said for cali
for san fran for los angeles for la
jolla for pittsburgh for detroit buffalo
that's the [ __ ] thing
salt lake county chicago right you don't
want to be sharing a breeze chicago is
going to sell out as well get those
tickets old towns almost sold out and
then we got rosemont so if you want to
come to old town we're only doing one
show in old town
get a ticket to rosemont come up and see
us
right t-bone oh yeah chicago roseman we
love you gang we'll see you next week
peace